what will American drug culture look
like once the drug war is finally over
and we could start to use more drugs in
more settings no one is better situated
to start this conversation than Hamilton
Morris the 32 year old host of
Hamilton's pharmacopoeia a show that
explores what sorts of drugs are
available how they work and how we might
best use them to fulfill our hopes and
dreams in one early episode Morris
confounds the conventional wisdom by
telling a positive story about PCP a
drug that even most legalized errs have
nothing good to say about he visits with
Timothy Wiley an artist and visionary
who uses the drug as part of his
creative process in another he gains
access to an abandoned laboratory housed
in a volcano that was once central to
the production of MDMA Morris also does
laboratory work at the University of the
Sciences in Philadelphia in which he and
his collaborators create new drugs for
testing and research trials he sat down
with reason to talk about how the drug
war has warped the discussion about
legal and illegal drugs and what the
post prohibition landscape will look
like why are you so interested in drugs
I need to think of a better answer to
that question because I get asked that a
lot
and it seems sort of self-evident that
they're very interesting it's like why
would somebody be interested in music or
food or something like that it but they
have an absolutely enormous influence on
our culture if people talk about drugs
as if it's some kind of niche subculture
but really it encompasses all of
Medicine so much of our political
landscape is dictated by drug policy and
the prison industrial complex I mean
it's a huge huge subject philosophically
medically scientifically it's a huge
huge thing so it structures everything
we do yeah I know it's when once you
start seeing the world through that lens
you realize that why wouldn't you be and
it would be crazy not to be interested
in this it's huge it's as big as
consciousness and our culture it's one
of the things that's interesting the way
that you talk about drugs and I say this
to somebody who's you know a kind of
cheerful enthusiastic user of drugs but
it's legal and illegal listen and
illicit but you know UD mythologized
them in a way and like a lot of people
who are at
drug culture either drug warriors or
kind of celebrators with drugs are like
oh these are magical substances that
have superpowers that we can't fully
understand so we have to control them it
seems like you're bringing a different
level of conversation to to this
discussion I would hope so yeah because
they don't think there's any benefit in
mythologizing them I see it in both
directions both positive and negative
people dramatically magnified the
virtues of certain substances while
demonizing others in ways that are
totally nonsensical and it creates this
sort of schizophrenic mentality
regarding drugs in the United States you
know sometimes these mythologies are
relatively innocuous whether it's you
know people starting to think that micro
dosing psychedelics is going to cure all
of society's problems probably not but
there's worse things that people could
believe but when it comes to other ideas
like for example you know the the crack
powder cocaine discrepancy it can have
you know major racial political criminal
implications for people that can really
interfere with you know can tear apart
families destroy lives whole societies
communities yeah so you know over the
I've got a few years on you and you know
it's exciting to witness the beginning
of the end of the drug war I mean you
know and that's being optimistic but why
do you think things are changing why
people seem to be more genuinely
interested in kind of grappling with
drugs and erasing this arbitrary
distinction between legal and illegal or
licit and illicit why does that happen
it's a good question I don't know
exactly I do know that in my history of
reporting on the subject which probably
started sometime around 2008-2009 I felt
that even then things were a little bit
different you know I would receive more
criticism for not having the same sorts
of opinions that were considered
orthodox at that time you've been
talking about something like
methamphetamine lightly was enough to
get criticized pretty severely and
there's still subjects like that that
you have to stick to a certain line or
LSU you end up getting chastised by the
public but you know I think the Journal
is largely driven by this swinging
pendulum of novelty and for a long time
it was novel and interesting and
engaging to report on how dangerous and
horrible and life destroying drugs are
that was a good story so somebody pulled
their eyes out on PCP somebody ate their
best friend somebody you know set
themselves on fire that's a good story
but then the novelty of scare stories
wears off and the pendulum swings in the
opposite direction and then it's more
engaging to say hey you know those
psilocybin containing mushrooms as magic
mushrooms that you thought were a drug
well it turns out that these guys at
Johns Hopkins they actually think it's a
medicine isn't that a novel take on all
this it turns out they're actually good
and so that becomes the predominant mode
of reporting on the subject and on that
level which is I understand that
somewhat cynical interpretation of the
media but I do think that there is a
sort of novelty that makes everyone
excited to say something different than
they've been what they've said in the
preceding decades what do you think of
things like Michael Pollan the food
writers book a year ago about how to
change your mind which is kind of an NPR
imprimatur Laden vision of psychedelics
is is that good or bad or does that does
that advance the conversation about
drugs or does it kind of is a part of
the problem oh it's absolutely good it's
it's very good it's almost impressively
good you know I was amazed by his
restraint and writing that book his
complete avoidance of any of the
scandalous information any of the
black-market history really of
psychedelics which is the majority of
the history of psychedelics most
psychedelics that have been consumed
haven't been consumed in the context of
a psychiatric clinical trial they've
been consumed illegally in an
unregulated black market and to create
this extremely palatable sterile history
of psychedelics that is if you read the
book cover-to-cover it's very hard for
any reasonable person to think
psychedelics are bad it makes a very
strong argument for it so on one level I
think fantastic you can ask for anything
more on
personal maybe more pedantic level I
sometimes resent how much emphasis is
placed on the clinical use of these
things because I sometimes think that
that sort of misses the point that these
things should be legal regardless of
whether or not they're viable treatments
for depression or OCD or anxiety or
end-of-life pain or any of these
different things that they do seem very
promising do you think that part of or
we're still we're in a framework even
even if we're getting outside of the
conventional wisdom of things it's still
we tend to look at drugs as medicine and
how does that limit the way that we
should be kind of experiencing them or
talking about them well I have nothing
against thinking of drugs as medicine
because they are I think that you know
the distinction between drugs and
poisons and medicines is sort of an
illusory distinction we've created all
these different categories that aren't
really chemically or pharmacologically
meaningful so I have no objection to
talking about drugs as medicines I just
don't want that to be the be-all end-all
of our understanding of the subject
because what if it turns out the
ketamine isn't as valuable a treatment
for depression as we think it is in 2019
we want to take it because we like how
we feel when we take it is that not
valid you know or then do we go back to
a prohibitionist interpretation of these
substances if the medical model fails I
mean I think there's something a little
bit precarious and fragile about the way
that we're barking down this path so I I
don't want to criticize it because it's
working really well from a political
perspective it's something that people
seem to agree with it's hard to argue
against somebody saying om BMA is a
valuable treatment for PTSD suffered by
Iraq veterans how can you argue against
that say oh no it shouldn't be used so
from that political perspective it's
brilliant it's extremely effective but I
think from a larger almost philosophical
perspective it's not the best way to
conceptualize drug policy in the United
States really it should be about Liberty
that you know individual autonomy owning
your mind
yes
what are your thoughts on Timothy Leary
in this kind of context because he is
you know in almost all discussions of
drugs and certainly hallucinogens and
psychedelics he's he's a looming figure
it's does he get a bad rap because he
took it out of the hands of the
laboratories and things like that and
brought acid to the masses and then kind
of went a little bit nuts you know is
what what can we learn from his presence
and kind of drug culture
well Timothy Leary certainly does get a
bad rap and it became very fashionable
to criticize him for a long time it
still is today and I think that that's
unfair I think that it doesn't really
acknowledge all the different factors
that order play at that time Timothy
Leary of course was an academic
psychologist and his initial steps in
this study of psychedelics were all done
academically but then it became clear
that this academic psychiatric model
wasn't going to sustain the psychedelic
movement Sandoz the pharmaceutical
company that is now Novartis withdrew
support you know they stopped
manufacturing LSD sometime around 1965
and that's a big deal that is the end of
any kind of capitalist pharmaceutical
support of psychedelics so after that
there was very little medical support
then they started making them all legal
and at that point it wasn't illogical
for Timothy Leary to emphasize this
non-medical understanding of
psychedelics because that was the most
effective tactic at that time his
strategy was to say okay the medical
model failed the psychiatric model
failed the pharmaceutical model failed
so let's go for a religious model let's
try and protect this use under the First
Amendment and maybe that's the way
forward well it turned out that didn't
work very well either and now he's
criticized horribly for you know ruining
medical scientific academic research
with psychedelics but he was there at
the beginning he tried there were many
factors that contributed to the
disintegration of that research I think
it was inevitable and I think to blame
Timothy Leary for being enthusiastic or
a zealot is sort of unfair you know you
wouldn't
get you wouldn't blame somebody who's
enthusiastic about alcohol for you know
alcohol prohibition if it occurred it's
not fair people should we should live in
a society where people can be
enthusiastic about something the real
issue is that the drug policy was in
such a precarious position that one
zealot could have such a major impact do
you do you think though he had to go
back to our earlier conversation about
kind of mythologizing did he oversell
the virtues of drugs perhaps it's an
interesting question I you know I happen
to also believe that psychedelics are
truly amazing substances and so when I
look at the way that he talked about
them at that time I think that there's a
little bit of a certain kind of pseudo
scientific wackiness that I don't agree
with but I think his awe is valid I
think that he really did see this
potential in them and I can't fault him
for that I can't fault him for his
enthusiasm in one of the most memorable
episodes of Hamilton's pharmacopoeias is
the is an episode about PCP and it's
titled a positive PCP story where you
offer up you know a positive version of
PCP talked about summarize that episode
and also comment on the
mischaracterization of the demonization
of PCP is kind of a shorthand for dumb
ways that we talk about drugs what's
going on in that episode and what can we
learn from the counter narrative that
you present yeah that episode is
actually how I started making the TV
show because at the time when this
television network of Iceland was
beginning I had proposed making a new
version of a TV show or an online TV
show that I've been making for several
years previously and one of the
executives said oh we already have this
tentative show and it's about all these
you know crazy drug stories and you know
PCP it's crazy and this drug
bromo-dragonfly it kills people it's
crazy let's do this let's talk about the
world's craziest drugs and I thought no
that's first of all the stories were old
they were bad it was poorly conceived
but but I said you know this is just a
stupid way of going about this it's been
done it's not even interesting why not
do something original
about how these things are actually
beneficial and not just the ones that
are you know undergoing some kind of
clinical scientific validation but the
ones that are still considered black
market commodities or our black market
commodities and he was saying well you
know there's some drugs that aren't bad
you have to acknowledge you can't say
that something like PCP is good and and
I said well sure you can oh yeah of
course you can and you can if you can
tell me a story about how PCP isn't bad
and we'll do that and and so that was
the pilot for Hamilton's pharmacopoeia
and and you know it's I think the PCP is
a perfect example of a drug that was
demonized by virtually everyone in and
outside of the drug community it got to
the point where it was shorthand for a
bad experience if you had something
negative happened to you you talked
about it like oh there must have been
PCP in it in the same way the people
would run it's laced with piece of lace
a piece of you're the same where they
blame strychnine for those it just
became the explanation for badness and
really it's a perfect example of a
substance that's been totally
mischaracterized because you know when
used carefully under controlled
circumstances it's no worse than
anything else pretty much every drug has
the potential to be extremely dangerous
under certain circumstances if you were
to you know people die from caffeine
overdose as it happens if you have
access to pure caffeine and you use it
recklessly you can get into trouble with
it and so what happens with PCP is the
way that it's used tends to be
unregulated people consume too much of
it there isn't an environment of any
kind of harm reduction ists drug
education that helps people use the
substance responsibly and so you know
there are problems you're careful to
avoid kind of moral terms like that you
know there are no bad drugs it's a
you're like a Catholic priest at a 1930s
movie there are no bad boys around only
bad but Arthur are there certain
substances or you know that are actually
just toxic or is it always the dose
makes the poison or the dose makes the
drop the positive side of the drug oh
there certainly are substances that are
so toxic that they have no value as a
recreational intoxicant you know and
most of those things people don't use
anyway really you know they're they're
obscure things like you know para chloro
amphetamine or something like that you
have most people haven't heard of that
but it's dad in fact the use of it has
been primarily psychiatric but those are
there are things that are dangerous and
they're things that are not well suited
to Street youths like fentanyl because
it's not that fentanyl is a bad drug in
fact it's a massive drug there's a
wonder drug yeah yeah yeah no it's in
you know a lot of brilliant people spent
their lives designing that substance
it's a it's a really amazing thing that
we should be grateful for but if you use
it without measuring the dose it can be
extremely dangerous and on top of that I
don't think it's what most people want
to begin with because it's it's not
really it has a very short duration it's
too easy to overdose on it most people
don't want fentanyl it's something that
is used deceptively to increase the
potency of things that are
misrepresented as heroin and again
that's something that emerges out of the
black mark right do you what are the
things that might propel a kind of late
broad-based both legalization I'm
changes in drug policy but also kind of
a change in our mental attitudes towards
drugs what are the types of events or
activities that might move that forward
and then what are the what are the
events that would set it back you know I
think that basic education is a really
crucial thing you know it's amazing to
me how many people have absolutely no
concept of dosage it just doesn't exist
in their mind and again that part of
that has to do with the black market so
you buy LSD
it's on blotter paper people say that it
contains 100 micrograms per dose but
they don't know they have no idea how
much they're taking so they don't know
the dose of what they're consuming that
already puts them at a disadvantage to
be able to critically evaluate what
they've done if you know exactly how
much you've taken you can then respond
accordingly and say well that last time
I took 80 micrograms I was actually
pretty strong I was a little bit
uncomfortable next time I'm going to
take 70 micrograms of LSD I think that's
a better dose for me and then you have a
more constructive informed relationship
with the substance but people can't make
that sort of assessment in a black
market economy because they don't know
what their take
they don't know the dose and so anything
that people can do to put themselves in
an informed position where they're using
things responsibly understanding the
dosa understanding the identity of the
materials that they're consuming I think
that that's like maybe the most
important thing possible but then you
know doing what you can to learn about
basic chemistry and pharmacology I think
that also helps a lot do you do you see
something like the way the opioid crisis
is being discussed I mean first off do
we have an opioid crisis and then is
that something that is going to slow
down kind of move into a post
Prohibition era or is it actually
something that might end up propelling
us there faster that's it's a
complicated question because certainly
people have argued that you know
liberalisation of cannabis law could
represent a solution to problems
associated in the use of opioid meaning
that people would be smoking pot rather
than taking heroin or what they exactly
oh yeah and I think that that probably
is true because there's a number of
people that for whatever reason they
probably really need to or want to be
intoxicated and so the question is how
can you do that in the least damaging
way possible in the same way that
there's a lot of people out there that
want some stimulant in the morning when
they wake up like you know and caffeine
happens to be a fantastic substance
because if it gives you that stimulation
in the morning but it doesn't produce
very there is a withdrawal if you
consume a lot of it and you stop
suddenly but for the most part it's a
pretty amazing substance and so that you
want to look for things like caffeine
and cannabis I think is almost like that
in that it's not a perfect substance
there are people that do develop
problematic relationships with it but
relative to alcohol and certainly
relative to the stronger opioids it
allows people to maybe cope with their
pain relax at the end of the day without
dramatically damaging their body or
their social and professional
functioning what are we getting wrong
when we talk about an opioid crisis well
I don't even you know the word that
people typically uses in crisis it's
epidemic right and I don't like that
term I think that there's a lot of
problems with it one is that it has this
it places the emphasis on the drug
and treats the drug like a disease which
it is not so if people talk about the
vaping epidemic the Joule epidemic well
how does that exist
you when you talk about it that way you
think oh maybe I'm on the bus and
there's someone next to me and they've
got a jewel maybe I'll catch the jewel
addiction it's part of the jewel
epidemic but that's not the way drug
addiction actually functions people as
uncomfortable as it is to say people do
need to take some responsibility for
their own behaviors and they need to
educate themselves and it's not as
simple as like a substance attacking
people indiscriminately and they have no
control whatsoever in these epidemics so
I think that the way that the the opioid
situation has been described as been
very it's shifted blame really on to one
small group of people the Sackler family
and we're gonna say okay it's cackling
Mortimer Sackler counting his blood
money or he's dead so in the grave up
counting his blood money and he's the
whole cause of all this and no one else
knew the doctors didn't know because
they were they were so hypnotized by his
brilliant advertising campaign in the
way that he infiltrated medical
education that no one ever knew that
opioids were addictive and of course the
patients didn't know either but I don't
think that's the case I think in fact
everyone knew I think the Sackler is new
I think the doctors knew I think the
distributors knew and I think in many
instances probably most instances the
patients know and so instead of creating
this this situation where we all pretend
that nobody understood anything why
don't we acknowledge the truth that we
actually did know and that almost
everyone played a knowing part in this
phenomenon take responsibility for what
happened and try to everyone should try
to conduct themselves more
constructively in the future and create
a support network for the people that do
develop problematic relationships with
opioids whether it's in giving them
agonist replacement therapy in the form
of buprenorphine or methadone or
whatever it is they might choose or you
know simply helping them with some other
form of rehabilitation where they can
stop using the drugs if they want to did
you have any when you were a kid in
school did you go through any drug
education programs sure yeah I went
through there yeah what what was your
what are your memories of that my
memories are
that it was absurd and it was being a
funny and counterintuitive and that it
certainly created interest in drugs you
know and it was if I remember correctly
I think was very dated as well you know
they're they're teaching people about
you know the dangers of barbiturates and
things like that when these things are
just essentially I'm not on the market
we're talking about PCP or LSD you know
I at this time I never even met anyone
who might in my age group that have used
LSD so these were it was if anything
that was sort of informing me about them
in a way that piqued my curiosity
because I could tell that it was
[ __ ] but but didn't make any
effective argument for why they
shouldn't be used you you create your
own drugs for research purposes yes what
is the decision tree on that like how
you know how do you decide well I want
to try and synthesize this or a
variation of this drug like how do you
go about figuring out what what to do
well it's investigational so you take it
typically there's a lead compound a
known compound one sort or another
depending on what I am researching and
how long with this chemist I work with
Jason Wallach will modify the structure
in various ways that we think might be
pharmacologically interesting and then
submit them for screening and I think
that's the way most medicinal chemistry
functions you know you make informed
guesses we don't so what's an example
you've you've played around with ambien
right yes recently I've been looking at
what why why why why is ambien a good
drug to kind of improve or restructure
well ambien is you know from a
pharmaceutical perspective it's an
immensely successful profitable and
effective substance but it also has all
these psychiatric side effects and the
nature of the side effects are not
pharmacologically understood you'd think
that something as big as ambien delirium
we must have an explanation for it but
we don't so it's been interesting to
look at various structural modifications
of the zolpidem molecule and see how
that might change it's binding at its
site of action which is the GABA a
receptor although we haven't even
started the pharmacological screening on
that this is just
your chemistry at this point I mean it's
it's a powerful drug and if you can make
it so that it's more effective with less
side effects that's a good thing and
this isn't even clinical this is just
you know this is simply you know
molecular neuropharmacology just kind of
trying to even even Invisalign be true
by the way so this is like just trying
to understand the most basic elements of
how these things function and how
different modifications of the structure
might change the way that it Dave's and
brain what is the best thing that you've
made and what is the worst best and
worst I mean there's things that have
interesting pharmacology but I don't
know that I can make that kind of a
assessment because it's it's not based
on the qualitative effects because it's
not the nature of the research it's
based on the binding and different
subtypes of receptors so it's you know
best in that case might be high
selectivity for a certain receptor like
5ht 1a or something like that are you
optimistic or do you do you think that
we're going to get into a more and more
kind of individualized biochemistry or
so that you will essentially be making
drugs for individual people based on
their chemistry and like a kind of
personalized molecular drug taking
that's an interesting question
um I think even with things like 23andme
there is increased appreciation of the
metabolic biochemical differences
between people you know certain people
have higher levels of this or that
catabolic enzyme and that does play a
role in response to various
pharmacotherapies I don't know if we're
at of level yet at a place where we can
individually tailor pharmaceuticals to
people's needs I think it would be
really interesting if it were possible
maybe has studying drug you know
pharmacology and kind of drug issues has
that changed your mind on other issues I
would say a little bit yes it has and
and one of them that I'm still a little
bit uncomfortable with but one is maybe
gun control on some level because I
often encounter this
in the realm of drugs where people will
say why don't smoke canvas so why would
I want cannabis to be legal or you know
someone who's straight will say oh I
don't I'm not gay so why should gay
people get to marry I'm not gay and and
then I and I of course recognized why
that is is stupid and and lacking
compassion in a horrible way to conduct
yourself and then I think about guns and
I think why maybe fall into that same
category in terms of I don't use guns I
don't like guns why should anyone be
allowed to have guns I think guns are
stupid and and so I think that maybe
encountering those same sorts of debates
in the realm of drugs has made me think
more carefully and critically about the
things that I'm against and not having a
knee-jerk reaction to assuming that they
should be prohibited just because I
don't like them you've if there are two
seasons of Hamilton's pharmacopoeia and
they you know that are archived online
and available a third seasons coming up
what what will be different about the
third season or what what drugs will you
be investigating well assuming that it
happens this is not certain at the
moment but there are a number of
different things that I want to
investigate you know I've been
interested in doing something about
methamphetamine chemistry for a long
time LSD chemistry is something that's
pretty fascinating something about the
the traditionals the traditions
surrounding ibogaine in central Africa
there's no there's a lot of fun projects
that I think would be really interesting
to explore so I do hope that I can get
back to filming soon alright well we'll
leave it there we've been talking with
Hamilton Morris thanks so much thanks
for having
[Music]